[Music]
on this sunday night more classroom
covered concerns
they're not prepared to have that start
on monday and that worries me as some
schools shift online and others press
ahead with in-person learning
rangers respond to remote areas hard hit
by covid i'm surprised that sticking
this
long a military boost for bearskin lake
first nation is it too little too late
africa's iconic initiative combating
climate change by planting a wall of
trees but will it work reunited at last
how an afghan baby boy is back with his
parents after their split-second
decision to hand him to a u.s soldier
global national
reporting tonight
mithu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
after an extended christmas break
triggered by surging cases of the
omicron variant students across much of
canada will return to school tomorrow
most students will be back to online
education but in western canada schools
will be open for in-person learning once
again most doctors agree opening schools
should be a priority for kids but
keeping those classrooms open may be
more challenging heather urex west has
our top story tonight
for the first day back after winter
break martinez stasiek is planning to
call her kids in sick neither of them
are feeling the greatest right now so
that
is being responsible on my part but the
calgary mom who also works at a local
preschool worries the province is
heading back to in-person learning too
fast they want us to do testing and
different masks
but they're not prepared to have that
start on monday
and that worries me while most of the
country has switched to online learning
students will be back in physical
classrooms across bc alberta
saskatchewan yukon and parts of the
northwest territories the parents in bc
and alberta have been warned schools
could be closed or there could be a
sudden shift to online learning if
omicron cases continue to rise so we've
certainly
given parents a heads up that we could
potentially be in situations where in
specific cases of a specific context
where schools or classes or grades are
moving online the alberta government has
promised to distribute better masks and
rapid antigen test kits to every student
once they return to class but many
schools have not received deliveries yet
rapid tests will be available for bc
students as well but not until much
later this month i think we're going to
see a fair amount of chaos over the next
little while
i don't think we're going to see
necessarily a large amount of severe
illness or bad outcomes but i think
there will definitely be a fair amount
of chaos dr lenora saxinger says recent
data out of the uk involving school-aged
children is encouraging despite a high
number of infections the number of
children hospitalized because of covet
has remained very low given that a lot
of kids have been vaccinated or
previously exposed and that the risk of
severe outcomes is low i think that for
a lot of people it is okay to
contemplate sending your child
to school the benefits of in-person
learning to a child's social and
emotional well-being cannot be
overstated but those benefits must once
again be weighed against kovit's risk to
their physical health heather york's
west global news calgary
a remote covid stricken first nation in
northwestern ontario is going to get
some military help but not as much help
as it asked for bearskin lake first
nation is about 600 kilometers north of
thunder bay more than half of the
community's 400 residents have tested
positive and nearly the entire community
is now in self-isolation david aiken
reports
on saturday three army rangers from cfb
borden in southern ontario flew to
bearskin lake for the day to assess what
resources a full military deployment
would need the community in bearskin
lake had asked for as many as 40
military personnel ready to stay for up
to 14 days they would have to
come up with their own tents
that's how bad it is in this situation
in my community it has been a week since
the chief asked for military help after
declaring a state of emergency in late
december i'm surprised i'm surprised
that has taken this
long and so slow the progress that's
been taken so far but finally on sunday
afternoon the federal government said it
would send help the government said four
army rangers are going in now and an
unspecified number later but the
community says they've been told
three now and three later for a total of
six
in any event a community spokesperson
said they are disappointed with the
response and still feel overwhelmed and
unsupported the 40 soldiers that the
community had asked for are needed to
spell off exhausted volunteers and
exhausted community leaders like the
chief who tested positive himself for
coven 19 on saturday i'm okay at the
moment but i wasn't feeling too
too good this morning but i think i'm
starting to feel okay now the chief got
sick even though he has had his booster
in fact 80 percent in the community are
fully vaccinated because of that there
have been no serious illness at least so
far that required medical evacuations
still with all but 20 or 30 of the
community's 400 residents locked in
self-isolation there is an urgent need
for people who can supply wood food and
medicine
and to provide relief for the
community's nurses there are less than
half a dozen looking after 200 sick
people i have
elderly parents at home
that they've been tested positive and
there's nobody to look after them
but i'm grateful the nurses go and check
upon them once
a day bearskin lake though just might be
the first of several remote northern
communities that are going to ask for
the military's help already we're
hearing from some northern manitoba
first nations communities that say
they'll be overwhelmed unless the
canadian forces pitches in nitu
david aiken in ottawa thanks david
quebec is reporting a sharp jump in
covet 19 related hospitalizations today
climbing by 140 since yesterday the
situation outside of montreal is
especially dire forcing some regions to
make tough decisions olivia o'malley
reports
hospitals in the laurentians north of
montreal are slammed all six in the area
are operating above full capacity
to relieve pressure the regional health
authority says it will move patients who
no longer need to be hospitalized to
long-term care facilities
in an email to global news a
spokesperson writes transfers will only
concern people who have tested negative
for covet 19. adding when they arrive
they must go through a confinement
period of 5 to 10 days we're surprised
we're kind of worried we don't want
seniors to be considered ours second
great citizens and we want to make sure
that this is done properly if it has to
be done the party quebecois health
critic is concerned mistakes from the
first wave could be made again in march
2020 hospital patients were transferred
to the province's long-term care homes
to free up beds
shortly after the outbreaks began nearly
4 000 people died in those facilities at
the start of the first wave in a report
the provincial ombudsman said the
government's strategy weakened chslds by
putting them in a position of over
capacity what we don't want happen is
for the public system to shove the
problem into the lawn care
home
facilities for them to be overloaded
critics worry the influx of patients
could strain an already thin staffing
situation resulting in a lack of
services
patients rights advocates don't agree
with transferring patients but they say
if it has to be done health measures
must be followed
well we should be better off and
hopefully they will do and act better
because otherwise
we will create another mess and horror
and people dying for
no reason the laurentian regional health
authority says it hopes to return to
normal as soon as it can it's currently
the only area in quebec transferring
patients critics hope it stays that way
olivia o'malley global news montreal
in new york at least 19 people including
nine children have been killed in an
apartment fire the five alarm fire broke
out this morning in a 19 story building
in the bronx more than 60 people were
hurt at least 13 are in critical
condition firefighters say they found
victims on every floor the fire is not
believed to be suspicious but the cause
is under investigation it is the
deadliest blaze in new york in more than
three decades
kazakhstan's health ministry says 164
people were killed during a week of
deadly protests that began over a sharp
rise in fuel prices kazakhstan will be a
key sticking point during top-level
talks between the u.s and russia that
begin tomorrow but the biggest will be
russia's threat against ukraine and how
president vladimir putin is amassing
troops along the border
jennifer johnson reports
despite two recent tense phone
conversations between u.s president joe
biden and russia's leader vladimir putin
russian troops remain near the border
with ukraine this week the u.s backed by
its allies will demand the kremlin stand
down there will be massive consequences
for russia if it renews its aggression
by which i mean economic financial and
other consequences that includes cutting
off russian banks from global
transactions
but whether putin is ready to negotiate
or finish the job he started in 2014
with the seizure of ukraine's crimean
peninsula remains a question the kremlin
wants ukraine barred from nato the white
house says that's non-negotiable but
remains hopeful our approach to
discussions will be pragmatic results
oriented and we believe there are areas
we can make progress on
three meetings are scheduled but already
russia's foreign minister is saying
talks could break down after the first
negotiators from nato and russia are
scheduled to sit down wednesday we need
to be
prepared
for
that
the talks breaks down and that
diplomacy will fail
and that's exactly why we are
[Music]
sending a very clear message to russia
that if they once again decide to use
military force against
a neighbor
then there will be severe consequences
the u.s has said it's open to discussing
limits on missile deployments and troop
exercises in europe but no troop
reductions
but fearing a war the pentagon has
already sent a portion of 60 million
dollars worth of military equipment to
ukraine ahead of these talks it's
another signal to putin that it won't
just be ukraine's army to fight should
russian troops invade
jennifer johnson global news washington
there were tears of joy on saturday
after relatives were reunited with an
afghan baby boy who went missing in
november during the chaos at kabul's
airport on saturday after weeks of
negotiations a 29-year-old taxi driver
who found two-month-old sohail ahmad in
the airport and has been looking after
him ever since agreed to give him back
to the boy's grandfather that's them
sitting there you'll remember these
distressing scenes the baby boy's father
worked as a guard for the u.s embassy in
kabul and handed sohail over the wall to
a soldier at the exact moment the
taliban took full control
coming up will he stay or will he go the
deportation decision for novant djokovic
plus
canada's critical step in protecting
mako sharks from extinction
we have some breaking news to bring you
now comedian and actor bob saget has
died at the age of 65. that is according
to police who say saget was found dead
in a hotel room in orlando florida
officers were called for reports of an
unresponsive man later identified as
saget who was pronounced dead at the
scene saget was best known for his role
as the jovial dad in the tv sitcom full
house no official cause of death has
been released it is decision day for
novak djokovic who is busy preparing for
a different kind of court battle whether
a judge will allow the world number one
a chance to defend his australian open
title or if he's set to be deported
the tennis star supporters have been
gathering outside an immigration hotel
in melbourne where djokovic is being
held he arrived in melbourne on thursday
but his visa was revoked by border
agents federal authorities have since
lost a request to delay the hearing
lawyers for djokovic say the nine-time
world champion was granted a medical
exemption because he tested positive for
covet 19 last month and has since
recovered
conservationists are praising the
federal government for helping to save
endangered sharks at a recent
international meeting canada
successfully lobbied for the protection
of short fin mako sharks it can be found
worldwide including off the coast of
nova scotia and even into the gulf of st
lawrence as ross lord explains mako
numbers are declining leading to fears
they could soon be extinct
with a top speed of 70 kilometers an
hour makos are considered the fastest
sharks in the atlantic ocean swimming
long distances well offshore to catch
their prey but the makos themselves are
a popular target for their meat and
their fins especially in parts of europe
they've just been overfished for years
now and there's been no limits at all on
how many you can catch for years nova
scotia's ecology action center lobbied
in vain at this international conference
to protect the endangered short fin mako
in november the 52 countries at the
commission for the conservation of
atlantic tunas agreed with science
indicating if harvesters keep fishing
the sharks they could become extinct
it's consensus based so if one party
doesn't agree that's it like the whole
thing goes out the window and so for
some years the u.s and the european
union blocked the protection
the ban prevents harvesters from fishing
or keeping makos even those that are
already dead landed as bycatch on boats
that are looking for other fish
for some fishers the ban goes too far
we're opposed to regulatory debt
discounts it's a bad practice okay
you've already killed it you're not
wasting it before the international ban
the federal government had already
imposed one in canadian waters becoming
a champion for shark conservation we've
seen this big shift over the last like
five years or so
with makos and with other sharks and
slowly putting things in place the
international restrictions are only
temporary they could be overturned by
pressure from commercial harvesters
suggesting the makos are not in the
clear just yet
ross lord global news
ahead africa's ambitious idea what the
great green wall could mean for climate
change and migration
you're watching global national
the effects of man-made climate change
are expected to be felt most severely in
the developing world in the coming
decades droughts in africa are already
affecting a giant project that itself is
trying to hold back the effects of
mother nature the so-called great green
wall initiative involves replanting
billions of hectares across the width of
the continent but as redmond shannon
reports the long-term consequences of
the plan are still unknown
thousands of years ago what is now the
sahara desert was green and lush it
dried out as part of a natural cycle of
climate change in recent decades
concerns about ongoing deforestation and
desertification led to a plan of action
the great green wall was launched in
2007. the initial idea was to build an 8
000 kilometer long forest from one side
of africa to the other it would be 15
kilometers wide and be used as a buffer
against deforestation
in 2012 the focus shifted from trees to
human development the wall became a set
of sustainable land use projects across
the belt so far it's thought about 15 of
the project has been completed however
drought and maintenance have been issues
this man in mauritania says he's barely
seen any rain in three years so
solar-powered pumps are being used to
irrigate palm trees barriers shield them
from the wind so they can shield
villages from encroaching sands
the country's environment minister says
it shows how the pan-african project is
about more than just planting trees it's
about improving the lives and skills of
those involved
this initiative in senegal looks to do
the same special circular gardens
designed to better resist drought
if successful the great green wall could
also help stem the tide of migration
from many parts of africa
any type of geoengineering project
because at the end of the day this is a
sort of a geoengineering project
they have to be validated with
scientific studies in montreal francesco
palzada is researching what the broader
consequences of planting so many trees
in these areas would actually be on
regional climates you know you think i
mean i'm just planting trees what is
going to happen by planting trees
but actually the vegetation has a very
strong feedback he says his ongoing
research suggests that could include
more rain but also more extreme
temperatures high and low as well as
more intense monsoons further afield
project coordinators say billions of
dollars more are needed to see the
mammoth project completed this decade
even though its long-term consequences
are still unknown redmond shannon global
news london
this is right off the wall as far as
community service goes next the bc man
using a transit bus to deliver kindness
to strangers
[Music]
a big wallop of winter isn't exactly the
norm on vancouver island so when it does
happen it can be difficult to deal with
in one seaside town a group of good
samaritans put their shovels musical
talents and a borrowed bc transit bus to
work to help clear out all the recent
snow kylie stanton reports
okay to travel
thank you jd ludlow may drive this bus
for a living
but what is it that drives him
good question i wake up every day
thinking how i can help others that's
what motivates me and so when he saw the
forecast for heavy snow
the wheels started turning so i thought
you know what i'm driving a bus i can
drive other shovelers around the valley
to help out ludlow also known as flower
man got the word out on social media
while securing an out-of-service bus
through bc transit the extra bus was
available and and jd and his team got
out there and really helped out in the
community which is what he does
musicians to politicians and everyone in
between got on board
then got to work
when you show up at a person's driveway
in a city bus
to uh you know clear the driveway and
the doors open you've got a musician
playing the music well this is right off
the wall as far as community service
goes thanks everyone win-win you know
for everybody involved really we
couldn't believe it it was like a
miracle it was a huge relief and boy
talk about generous i'm so glad we found
you well i'm glad i'm i'm i'm more glad
that you found me
believe me it's proof a little goes a
long way stretching even further when
times are tough you know we need to help
our neighbors
we you know we've been talking about
keeping safe for the last few years
but we also need to look out for each
other in other ways too
plans are already in motion to continue
the work but for now the 22 centimeters
of snow that blanketed the community is
melting thank you very much along with
the many hearts touched by this random
act of kindness i'm so grateful to
to help others and that's what drives me
every day kylie stanton
mobile news
what an inspiration while an artist in
bc's haida gwaii region got extra
creative with all that snow take a look
at these incredible creations by billy
yovanovich jr if you're clearing snow
you may as well keep it beautiful right
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm nithu garcia thanks for
watching donna friesen will be back at
the anchor desk tomorrow have a great
night
[Music]